هل يمكنني أن أسألك عن المثليين، ويبدو أن
هناك جنوبًا عالميًا
يكره
حقوق الأخلاق الغربية،
وعندما يتعلق الأمر بالمثليين، يقولون إنك
تعرف لماذا يجب عليهم الالتزام، وأنا
أتحدث عن نفسك أيضًا من خلال
المفاهيم الغربية للمثليين.  الحقوق وقد
ظهر ذلك أيضًا في أه محاولات كأس العالم
القاسية لحمل الناس على عدم
رفع علم قوس قزح
وما إلى ذلك،
وهناك شعور بأنه
نوع من نوع عدم السؤال وعدم إخبار
الموقف  في قطر ولكن الناس يعيشون
خائفين، يعيش الأشخاص المثليين خائفين في
منطقتك، في جميع أنحاء منطقة الخليج،
حديث جدًا أن ما هو ما هو
الخطأ، كما
تعلم أنك قلت بالفعل إن
الدولة الإسلامية لا ينبغي أن تخاف من
النساء  خائف من أنك تعرف
كل هذه الأشياء الأخرى وليس لديك ما
يلزم لجعل المثليين
مقبولين مع منحهم حقوقهم ومعاملتهم
مثل الآخرين. حسنًا،
أعتقد أنه أولاً وقبل كل شيء، هذا النقاش
والجدال لا يحدث بشأن
ما  - يسمى الجنوب العالمي فقط، إنه
يحدث حتى في الغرب، ويحدث في
أمريكا، ويحدث في مكان آخر، وفي
كل مكان، لكن هذا يجعل الأمر
صحيحًا
فقط لإنهاء وجهة نظري هنا، قطر
بلد يحب مجتمعنا
الحفاظ على التقاليد وهم
فخورون جدًا بها.  عقيدتهم وهذا
شيء غير مقبول في عقيدتنا
مقارنة ذلك بالمرأة
المشاركة في المجتمع هذا
أه هذا مختلف ليس هناك شيء في
عقيدتنا يمنع النساء لا ولكن
القندهاريين يقولون هناك نعم هذا
تفسيرهم ولكنه موجود  في ما
نعرفه وما نعرفه في تاريخنا
والذي نفتخر به، هل توافق على أن
هؤلاء الأشخاص لديهم الحق في أن يكونوا آمنين نعم
ولا أحد منهم آمن،
كون سلامتهم تخضع كما تعلم طالما أنهم
يحترمون القانون في الأماكن العامة
مناطق لا يوجد أحد فيها سلامتهم موضع شك،
أعني أنك لا ترى جرائم الكراهية
تحدث في قطر بسبب المثليين أو
بسبب هذا أو بسبب ذلك أه
انظر إلى سجل تاريخ قطر في
الخمسين سنة الماضية
وقارنه فقط بأي دولة أخرى  بلد
في أوروبا،
يمكنك رؤية جرائم الكراهية في أوروبا
ضد مجتمع المثليين
بالآلاف في العام الماضي تحدث في بعض
الدول الأوروبية الحديثة لن أذكرها
وكانت قطر صفرًا،
ما نقوله هو أن هذه هي
قوانيننا وأدوارنا وثقافتنا لأي شخص
يريد أن يأتي  هنا مرحب به طالما
أنه يحترم كما يتوقعون منا
ومن الناس أن يحترموا
قوانينهم وأعرافهم، أعني أننا
نسير في أوروبا في الدولة الغربية
إذا فعلنا شيئًا لا يحترم هناك
نقول لشعبنا ذلك
سيحاسب على ذلك لأن
وظيفتك هناك هي احترام
البلد المضيف الذي تملكه وهذا
ما نتوقعه من الآخرين